surely you flick in the check to make  the Black Knight go passive first and  then play Knight H4 because now what can  happen is this Knight can spring out to  G5 in a bunch of lines and this F3  Square David if you want to highlight it  uh can be very very tender and this is  totally weird what Rapport is doing and  it doesn't surprise me at all that the  bar has gone completely insane of a  Magnus this bishop is just a terrible  piece this bishop is a potential monster  so surely we don't let them both  disappear from the board for example if  you take the White Knight will come back  and capture and what it should be fine  here maybe  but uh actually even in this type of  position you have to worry about the  black queen coming in attacking this  Pawn this pawn and this Pawn uh this one  is a bit complicated but Lawrence you  were talking about the potential of the  light squares and he actually uses that  square you highlighted in this position  he dropped back with his Bishop